that's recording on that camera too
lovely
all right
hello i'm tom scott and i've got a story
for you it's set in a future not
necessarily the future i'm not saying
this is what will happen but i think
it's a plausible path from where we are
now to where we will be and where we
will be is april 2022 10 years time
first person we're going to meet there
is jason stewart he's the mp for tooting
and stretton uh he is the minister for
social development he's considered kind
of a hot shot among his party after
winning his seat in the 2020 general
election a very hard-fought contest also
embroiled in a massive scandal but we'll
get back to that in a minute this is the
2022 iphone looks about the same the
laws of physics dictate you still need a
battery brick but what has changed is
the mobile network speed 5g now blankets
the country in 100 megabit internet
access and the data caps are a thing of
the past which means that last year
apple reused a trademark and introduced
ilife it's quite similar to your history
on microsoft nokia phones or droid
locker on android they're all
descendants of the accountability
systems that have been used for police
officers and care workers for years now
with ilife the phone is always recording
audio and sending it and your location
to a cloud server the descendants of
siri then generate a transcript of it if
you're talking to someone else with
ilife it'll give you a text chat log
it's not perfect but it's close enough
and if you have the new apple headset
it's got a couple of cameras embedded in
it which are always recording video when
they're connected that's uploaded
analyzed and stabilized by the same
systems the cable instantly still gets
tangled in knots every time you put it
in your bag
what this means is that you can say to
people this is what i'm looking at right
now this is what i just looked at it's
all hooked up to social networks this is
what people use it for justin bieber's
comeback tour was live streamed around
the clock and never went below 50 000
viewers
what's more important though is that
ilife gives you a life long a complete
history every person you've talked to
every friendly smile every strange you
have passed in the street your own
memory is now indexed augmented
searchable in your first 50 gigs of
storage are free
and if you think that's far-fetched
let's remember facebook is less than 10
years old twitter is only six years old
and the iphone itself five years we've
gone from t9 text entry to full voice
dictation in half the time we're talking
about here which brings us back to jason
stewart jason is a member of cheshire
boys the site for his old alumni of his
public school runs on disco a fairly
popular community framework that
unfortunately has some fairly major
security flaws including one that allows
mass stealing of passwords now let's go
to russia natalia orlowski is there she
is 15 she lives in an ex-soviet tower
block and she doesn't get out much she's
running a bot that pulls in as many of
those passwords as possible not for
anything particularly evil she saw what
happened to the group that charged pawn
to putin's credit card last year
but
because she can she takes all these
passwords she bundles them together and
she puts them out on a paceman side
because she can it's just another big
leak there have been loads of them
before
and facebook and all the networks will
of course lock everyone's account down
and require they change their password
again but in the meantime lots of people
are looking through this list and one
person is going to notice two team jason
at gmail.com
his password is stuart9 that's the same
password he uses everywhere and someone
goes hey let's log into his icloud first
thing they see is apple's handy is this
you feature jason stewart can be seen in
a few frames of this walk by in
shoreditch he wasn't recording but his
phone had his location and facial
recognition did the rest and it didn't
take too much effort to find out what he
was doing there
a few minutes later this poison pen
letter arrives in every single political
editor and bloggers inbox in the country
the sun eventually runs with it first
after all the blogs have made it public
knowledge and jason stewart's career
is ruined
except it's not
because he's not committing a crime
under uk law he's divorced so he wasn't
even committing adultery it's 2022 he
decides he's going to go on the offense
he gets up in parliament and says that
our private lives should be private and
that we must investigate these hackers
and he convinces the met to investigate
which they do by filing a request with
apple for any life logs that mention
jason stewart in the hours and minutes
before the leak and apple agrees because
that argument got settled years ago
after blackpool
so that's the way it works now
someone's arrested 16 years old so they
can't be named but we know they've been
released on bail on the grounds that
they not use the internet or a computer
which means of course that they can't do
anything and that's the president said
if you're in the same area as the victim
of a crime or you say the same name as a
victim of a crime in the minutes or
hours before your life log will get
pulled and searched through by the
police
and you can always close your account
and opt out of course that option
is right there but
it's so damned useful
and besides all your friends use it and
besides lots of companies are requiring
that their employees use it for
liability purposes and besides all that
it's not like you've got anything to
hide
right
i'm tom scott thank you very much
[Applause]
you